which is lame bro they should let chicks
you know let the titties fly dude bro
it's good business for everybody isn't
it it's good for everyone
[Music]
so something that's
um
it's been pretty big everywhere
everyone's kind of talking about it is
G4 got shut down oh you guys remember G4
you guys know G4 I'm not too familiar
with G4 what is this gaming are you a
nerd yeah dude that's sick
could you tell yeah no I like I didn't
know that I'm a nerd really oh you're a
fake ass hurt again not like a jock but
like nerd like games techies yeah gaming
I guess people gaming this is weird
[Laughter]
in that world but yeah yeah bro video
cards dude
are you just naming cried at the end of
Final Fantasy when he finished it was
that's the last time I cried that's sick
I don't even played those games but I
know all about them through every other
major event
before a really big Network back in the
day that you know put gaming on a
different Spotlight did a lot of gaming
content had some good shows
um and so they they launched originally
2002 and then they actually stopped 2014
and then they did the big relaunch where
they were bringing it back and that was
with all the oog people yeah and then
yeah and then Gina from here went there
and then within a year of them of their
relaunch they're now done again did it
go to television or was it on stream
because I know it's streaming as well
yeah it kind of depends because I know
that like I could get it on my Vizio TV
for like Vizio watch you know like the
TV that channels that come yeah yeah
they had that there I don't I'm not sure
where else you could find it because
yeah you know it's that's a little
harder to just run into it but then they
did do a lot of YouTube content and
everything and the budget looked huge
the shows were great yeah yeah the other
dude they're like an ex-wrestler didn't
they I don't want to [ __ ] up his name it
wasn't bulk Bogan
I don't want to [ __ ] up his name I think
it was a WWE wrestler who's like a nerd
oh I don't know he's like where was Omar
he's like a Megan nerd and I think he
retired from wrestling and came on those
shows too like they had like power
behind it like they had like celeb power
yeah they had strong stuff they and they
they gave a lot of like internet
personality their own legit shows yeah
Scott the wise had his own show there
were a lot of good stuff classically my
favorite thing to watch on G4 back in
the day was this thing I don't know if
you remember this street Fury what it
was all about like import cars and
import models that is sick wow you never
saw this stuff right I was just about to
say that it's my Jeep whoever she is
find this girl for Mike that's my type
right so like the type of posters you
have in here yes do you follow Kayla on
Instagram
yeah that's pretty cool that's a really
cool thing but yeah G4 within and the
sucky thing is you know that's 47 people
that are being laid off from G4 closing
a lot of them didn't find out about it
until the world found out like they
released like a statement and then
that's how they knew like they're
finding out right now from this video
kinda it was like yesterday's yesterday
yeah yeah and the CEO like just like
tweeted like a tweet longer it was like
yeah it's a bit longer yeah that sucks I
hate it when I see those things Tucky
way to find out yeah yeah like they
can't just like five minutes before goes
hey like there's gonna be a press
release that FYI we all lost our job
Ninja Warrior was on that channel Ninja
Warrior oh really
yeah what if they're experiencing a much
bigger level of us where like their ads
get pulled too well that's exactly what
happened their main investor was Comcast
and they pulled out wow yeah in my head
is just a television issue right when
you talk about any shows you're watching
it's like Netflix originals now HBO
Originals even even prime yeah and who
knows what the real like actual issue is
but the one that kind of like a lot of
other people are saying it is that are
sort of in that World
um one of the main things is that
viewership was too low for how much they
were spending because the the production
when you look at the show they're like
legit shows like yeah they look like the
old G4 exactly it kind of I thought it
looked even better I was like dude this
is like made for like now and it was
like powering through but when it comes
to gaming it's like most kids just watch
Gamers like streams yeah it's not really
like it's very like if to do long form
in like old school format even if you're
like kind of rebranding for the new
school still how do you compete with a
kid who has more people watching him and
he's spending zero to you know sit there
and play his games and that you get the
genuine connection from that yeah that's
hard especially on Twitch where some
people are just taking baths you know
and people will watch that hot tub what
a great segue you
the issue here with the hot tubs is that
they were locking down on like nudity
and anything like that so uh and then it
was like some sexism stuff where like
guys were allowed to be shirtless ladies
weren't so like all right you can only
be in that environment or or that outfit
if you're in that environment so you
can't just be wearing a bikini streaming
games that's what they were doing and
then guys would do whatever and they're
like you have to be at a beach a pool
whatever so then uh she brings her whole
setup
I'm sorry I'll show that the opposite
they'd be do it blow up they do a green
screen yeah they do a blow-up pool and
they just sit in their living room dude
which is lame bro they should let chicks
you know let the titties fly dude bro
it's good business for everybody isn't
it it's good for everyone it's good
almost almost who's it bad for tell me
right now who's about but you know a lot
of them for some reason shut down though
like Tumblr shut down their their porn
nudity
um there's a thing called Africa TV in
Korea that was huge like uh content
creators were making like Africa TV free
a free area what are you upset about
that yeah yeah yeah yeah he was pissed I
just want to know how it was spelled
just because of curious yeah like it's
got a k there are content creators
working like 45 000 a week but then they
stopped their nudity stuff remember when
only fans did yeah the only fans they
always that was funny they stopped it
for like a day but they do that like
Tumblr they they all for some reason at
some point go hey you know what you
can't be naked on patreon no you can't
yeah like actual I think patients you
could pay for it I thought no that's
what made only fans its thing we're like
only fans I don't know who the Creator
heard his interviews or anything but I
imagine he was just making a platform
similar to patreon but then he never
ruled the nudity and then it became
pseudo porn or porn where I don't think
patreon I've never heard of it oh wow I
don't think you show PPE or nothing on
patreon yeah that's what everybody's
trying to sign up for so it starts with
a P I was trying to say no not PE but PP
you know like it's just more innocent
you say it that way I feel like
patreon's way more clean thank you for
explaining bro I was just I was just
trying to light it in
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
well yeah G4 is a good Channel but again
like seeing it and seeing the budget
that goes into it they probably just had
such a high uh threshold for what they
needed to hit in order to maintain that
investor hey I mean but that's [ __ ]
hard man yeah it's like they're they're
trying to do new school content with an
old school vehicle
which is tough right now I mean that's
the thing it's it's like when you when
you watch it it's not bad like it is
good it's just our how do you get people
over there yeah that's the main thing
you probably just signed a contract with
Netflix or something right you pitch you
pitch more of a series than a TV channel
yeah and that's how you get up in yeah
some things with kids watching because
right now like their attention spans
what five to ten seconds and then these
shows are unimaginable well it depends
because there's also kids that watch
24-hour streams yeah it's actually yeah
we're just we're just getting more
extreme kids are able to watch the same
thing over and over and over and over
again that's one thing that's always
been true so like you and On Demand too
versus TV it's like when you turn it on
you're just stuck either you start from
the middle of the show or at the end of
the show you can't control versus I want
to watch the beginning now I think their
attention span is short with advertising
so if their attention span is short with
getting them to know about a certain
product so like if you don't get to the
[ __ ] point that you should watch this
thing within the first five seconds
they're already somewhere else yeah but
if they know they like it they don't
want to [ __ ] move from that [ __ ] like
they have such strong allegiances to
people like Ludwig or like Ninja they
will never [ __ ] turn their backs on
like who they like or even Mr Beast like
they know they like him that's it and
you know once you get him there that's
good but again like the format's
different when you follow individuals
these days putting a program like G4
maybe there was a problem with that or
they never nailed how to do it yeah but
it was arguably it was very good very
good content what's that TV channel
that's made it like what's the newest TV
channel
maybe like spikers yeah spikes of what
Pops in my head and that's like what 20
maybe maybe Barstool TV if that exists
as like a channel I don't think any like
TV wise I I just really don't think
there's a market for that anymore it
depends when's the last time you turned
on TV and what were you watching I love
it's usually Sports what do you do I
don't have TV but I love it I feel like
the movie when I'm scrolling this might
get a little you know spiritual but I
feel like when I'm scrolling I feel like
the movie chose me I [ __ ] with that
when a movie pops up and it just happens
to be there I can enjoy it more than if
I'm like I wouldn't choose this movie
right now but it's on so I gotta watch
it I can't choose a movie yeah so like
for instance if you go on Samsung TV a
lot of the channels that we watch are
things like there's a channel where it's
just Kitchen Nightmares 24 hours a day
yeah there's one where it's just wilding
out 24 hours a day it's a lot of the
same [ __ ] there's a people or awesome
Channel where it's just that there's a
fail blog channel where it's just that
but you don't really get a lot of
channels that have like a variety of
stuff coming at you even stuff that's
game theme there's a channel on Samsung
TV that is nothing but a guy playing a
game just like twitch and he's playing
the same game so it's it's very
different it's like maybe the whole like
variety pack of thing kind of doesn't
sell as well as if you just give someone
the [ __ ] Flaming Hot Fritos all the
time but then when I feel like what new
TV shows that do really well they get
packaged on like Netflix or like
nowadays Hulu is like if it's networked
but the thing is they are bingeable for
a reason yeah you were allowed to go
through that whole [ __ ] if you if you're
down to commit that time I think that's
a metric somewhere that somebody went oh
people want this yeah they don't want
one episode you know like and then you
gotta wait that's not ideal yeah yeah
didn't Cartoon Network just get bought
up or die too yeah no this week they
just ended the Cartoon Network thing and
it gets absorbed in a WB yeah hey you
know what Discovery yeah yeah yeah
that's tough man but yeah you gotta
scale back or you gotta you know try
something else just so you have a Vizio
TV and a
[Laughter]